michael is in atlanta hey michael
welcome to the ramsay show
hey how's it going better than i deserve
what's up
um so i'm currently on baby step two and
i'm starting the process where i
do the debt snowball and really wipe out
my debts baby step two says you should
pay off all debts except for the house
using the snowball and in my case i
wanted to see if that would be the
scenario
my debts are probably a little higher
than average because i'm running a
practice in the business
okay so what are you what are you
talking about you've got a business debt
that you signed personally for
it's a personal debt but how much is it
ultimately
so right now my practice status about
eight hundred thousand dollars
yeah and then my college tuition is
about 185
thousand dollars uh college tuition you
mean student loan debt
correct yes um student loan debt goes in
baby step two eight hundred thousand
dollar practice goes
in baby step six okay yeah so you
consider that as part of like the
same concept just paying off the home
early then yeah yeah
and i would call it um here's a here's a
kind of a
correlation on that if you will although
the numbers
aren't as many zeros but if you're if
you have a home equity loan we put it in
baby step
two if it's less than half your annual
income
if it's more than half your annual
income we put it in baby step six with
the house
so pray tell please tell me you have an
incredible income with this delicious
mess you've made
luckily the first year of the business
my take home was pushing 250. so
luckily i'm producing more than i'm
spending and i have the ability to
snowball with that
okay so um you said practice what
you're a medical doctor or a dentist a
dentist
excellent okay now the most expensive
form
okay so you netted 250 last year
correct that's my net income what do you
think you're going to get this year
uh i'm aiming up at the 300 but i'm
taking a step at a time with
covid things went all over the place so
we'll see so you're going to try to live
on
you're going to try to put at least 200
a year towards this mess right
that's at least the plan yeah i'm still
living on almost a college budget
i like that i like that that's hard to
do
when you're making a quarter of a
million dollars a year emotionally but
it is the right thing to do and the
smart thing to do
because you have a large mess to go with
your large income
yeah yeah but that's a scary number to
look at so that's my motivation yeah and
i think if you
here's what i'd be looking at how
stinking wealthy you're going to become
instantly when you clear the table on
all this debt
i mean you got a million dollars here in
just student loans and practice debt
alone
and so when you clear that million
dollars off the top of your head and
you're making three 350
you're gonna make so much money so fast
it's gonna be unbelievable but the
temptation is to drag that out
for a lot of people and that's a huge
mistake we've worked with a lot of
a lot of guys and gals in the dental
world over the years and that's uh
it is you guys spend more money than mds
do
on your practices and on your education
it's it's shocking
but the good news is you got a good
practice that you stepped into so i'm
glad for you
yeah play through baby play through good
stuff
wow yeah got to keep the eye on the
prize i hope you folks heard what dave
said
because that's such a huge mountain
right but then you got to go what's it
like on the other side of that mountain
and and that's when you start piling up
money and you go okay how long do i want
to be a dentist well
25 years well you know you busted over
the next two three years you know four
years backs
really get after it you're on the other
side of that mountain well it's really
fun
you know once you get up there and you
know i i think of
there's a great story of uh sir edmund
hillary who climbed mount everest the
first time and he was with his climbing
partner they finally get up there and
you can imagine how difficult that
journey was way back then he finally
gets up at the highest point in looking
out and that's really this idea of
getting over debt
and and if you get so consumed with how
difficult the climb is
many people fall off but if you're going
hey i want to be the first person to
summit that i'm going to summit that
that's what we're about that's the
vision
when you get up there here's what's
great on the other side of these
debt-free screams that you hear on this
show
people are now looking out they've been
looking up during the journey but then
when you finally get up there and edmund
hillary looked at his friend he's
climbing
sherpa partner he said i think that's
the next one we're gonna climb
isn't that amazing on top of the world
five minutes later
i think that's the one we're gonna climb
but now the vision is this way
yeah you start seeing different it's a
different viewpoint
and that's um it is half the battle in
the stuff we talk about around here from
dr john talking about mental health to
money to careers
to uh you know all the different types
of things we get ourselves into around
ramsey
so much of it has to do with the view it
has to do with the perspective
and uh you know they say that it's
easier to make second million
sure it is because you've already done
it once and you believe you can do it
it's always easier i know i've done it
twice because i was so stupid i had to
do it twice
there you go